and the error that some people are doing  is that they are wearing a black suit to  their regular consulting job this is a  typical error because again black suits  are usually formal attire for formal  events not for your day-to-day business  not for your day-to-day clothing so what  type of shoes should you wear instead  well these are darker suits that are not  black though the typical colors would be  an anthracite so dark anthracite color  another typical color would be just a  dark gray tone for instance something  like this that you could wear or also a  dark blue personally I really like dark  blue just in general as a color and also  for suits I think this often fits really  well